the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today we're continuing with improper
integrals I still have a little bit more
to tell you about them what we were
discussing at the very end of last time
was improper integrals and these were
going to be into improper integrals of
the second kind by second kind I mean
that they have a singularity at a finite
place that would be something like this
so here's the definition if you like
same sort of thing as we did when the
singularity was in infinity so if you
have the integral from zero to one of f
of X this is going to be the same thing
as the limit as a goes to zero from
above the integral from a to one of f of
X DX the idea here is the same one that
we had at infinity let me draw a picture
of it you have imagined a function which
is coming down like this and here's the
point one and we don't know whether the
area enclosed is going to be infinite or
finite and so we cut it off at some
place a and we let a go to zero from
above so really it's zero plus so it's
we're coming in from the right here and
we're counting up the area in this chunk
and we're seeing as it expands whether
it goes to infinity or whether it tends
to some finite limit right so this is
the example and this is the the
definition and just as we did for the
other kind of improper integral we say
that this converges that's the key word
here if the limit is finite
exists maybe I should just say and
diverges if not if not let's just take
care of the basic examples first of all
I wrote this one down last time we're
going to evaluate this one the integral
from 0 to 1 of 1 over the square root of
x and this just almost you almost don't
notice the fact that it goes to infinity
this goes to infinity as X goes to 0 but
if you evaluate it first of all we we
always write this as a power right to
get the evaluation and then I'm not even
going to replace the zero by an a I'm
just going to leave it as zero the
antiderivative here is X to the one half
times two and then I evaluate that at
zero and one and and I get to two minus
zero which is two
all right so this one is convergent and
if not only is it convergent but we can
evaluate the second example being not
systematic but really giving you the
principal examples that we'll be
thinking about is this one here DX over
X and this one gives you the
antiderivative is the logarithm
evaluated at zero and one and now again
you have to have this thought process in
your mind that you're really taking the
limit but this is going to be the log of
1 minus the log of 0 really the log of 0
from above there is no such thing as the
log of 0 from below and this is minus
infinity so it's 0 minus minus infinity
which is plus infinity and so this one
diverges
all right so what's the general so more
or less in general let's just for powers
anyway if you workout this thing for DX
over X to the P from zero to one what
you're going to find is that it's 1 over
1 minus P when P is less than 1 and it
diverges for P bigger than or equal to 1
now that's the the final result if you
if you carry out this integration it's
it's not difficult alright so now I just
want to try to help you to remember this
and to think about how you should think
about it so I'm going to say it in a few
more ways all right just just repeat
what I've said already but try to get it
to percolate and and absorb itself and
in order to do that I have to make the
contrast between the kind of improper
integral that I was dealing with before
which was not as as X goes to 0 here but
as X goes to infinity the other side
let's make this contrast first of all if
I look at the angle that we've been
paying attention to right now we've just
considered things like this 1 over X to
the 1/2 which is a lot smaller than 1
over X which is a lot smaller than say 1
over x squared which would be another
example this is as X goes to 0
so this one's the smallest one this
one's next smallest and this one is very
large on the other hand it goes the
other way at infinity as X tends to
infinity right so so try to keep that in
mind and now I'm going to put a little
box around the bad guys here this one is
divergent and this one is divergent and
this one is divergent and this one is
divergent when we the crossover point is
1 over X when we get smaller than that
we get to things which are convergent
when we get smaller than it on this
other scale its convergent all right so
these guys are divergent so they
associate associated with divergent
integrals the the functions themselves
are are just tending towards well this
one these tend to infinity in these 10
towards 0 I'm not talking about the the
functions themselves but the integrals
now I want to draw this again here not
small enough I want to draw this again
and so I'm going to just draw a picture
of what it what it is that I have here
but I'm going to combine these two
pictures so here's the picture for
example of y equals 1 over X all right
that's y equals 1 over X and that
picture is very balanced it's symmetric
on the two ends if I cut it in half then
what I get here is two halves and this
one has infinite area that corresponds
to the integral from 1 to infinity DX
over X being infinite and the other
piece
which this one we calculated last time
this is the one that we just calculated
over here in example two has the same
property it's infinite and that's the
fact that the integral from zero to one
of DX over X is infinite
all right so both we lose on both ends
on the other hand if I take something
like drawing it the same way but it's
really not the same y equals 1 over the
square root of XY y equals 1 over X to
the 1/2 and if I cut that in half here
then the X to the 1/2 is actually bigger
than this guy so this piece is infinite
and this part over here actually is
going to give us an honest number in
fact this one is finite and we just
checked what the number is it actually
happens to have area 2
and what's happening here is if you if
you would super impose this graph on the
other graph what you would see is that
they cross and the this one sits on top
so it if I if I drew this one and let's
have another color here orange let's say
if this were orange if I set it on top
here it would go this way okay and
underneath the orange is still infinite
so both of these are infinite on here on
the other hand underneath the orange is
infinite but underneath where the green
is is is finite that's a smaller
quantity infinity is a lot bigger than
two two is a lot less than infinity all
right so that's reflected in these
comparisons here if you like if I want
to do these in green this guy is good
and this guy is good now let me just
repeat that idea over here in this sort
of reverse picture with y equals one
over x squared if I chop that in half
then the good part is this end here this
is finite and the bad part is this part
of here which is way more singular and
is infinite all right so again what I've
just tried to do is to give you some
geometric sense and also some some
visceral sense this guy it's tail as it
goes out to infinity is much lower it's
much smaller than 1 over X and these
guys trap an infinite amount of area
this one traps only a finite amount of
area
alright so now I'm just going to give
one last example which combines these
two types of pictures it's really
practically the same as what I've said
before but I have to erase this one too
all right so here's another example if
you're if you're if you're in let's
let's take the following example this is
somewhat related to the first one that I
gave last time if you take the function
y equals 1 over X minus 3 squared you
think about its integral so let's think
about the integral from 0 to infinity DX
over X -3 squared and suppose you were
faced with this integral in order to
understand what it's doing you have to
pay attention to two places where it can
go wrong we're going to split it into
two pieces I'm going to say break it up
into this one here the up to five for
the sake of argument and say from 5 to
infinity all right so these are the two
chunks now why did I break it up into
those two pieces because what's
happening with this function is that
it's going up like this
at 3 and so if I look at the two halves
here I'm going to draw them again and
I'm going to illustrate them with the
colors we've chosen which are I guess
red and green what you'll discover is
that this one here which corresponds to
this piece here is infinite and it's
infinite because there's a square in the
denominator and as X goes to 3 this is
very much like if it shifted the 3 to 0
very much like this 1 over x squared
here but not in this context in the
other context where it's going to
infinity
this is where it this is the same as as
the picture directly above with the
infinite part in red alright and this
part here this part is finite alright so
since we have an infinite par plus a
finite part the conclusion is that this
thing well this guy converges then this
one diverges but the total unfortunately
diverges right because it's got one
infinity in it so this thing this thing
diverges and that's what happened last
time when we got a crazy number
if you integrated this you would get
some negative number if you wrote down
the formulas carelessly and the reason
is that the calculation actually is
nonsense you've got to be aware when
you're going to if you encounter a
singularity in the middle not to ignore
it yeah question
why do we say that the whole thing
diverges the the reason why we say that
is the area under the whole curve is
infinite it's the sum of this piece plus
this piece and so the total is infinite
we're stuck this is an ill-defined
integral it's one where your red
flashing warning signs should be on
because you're not going to get the
right answer by computing it you'll
never get an answer similarly you'll
never get an answer with this and you
will get an answer with that okay yeah
another question so the question is if
you have a little if you have a little
glance at an integral how are you going
to decide where you should be heading so
I'm going to answer that orally although
you know but I'll say one little little
hint here so you always have to check X
going to infinity and X going to minus
infinity if they're if they're in there
and you also have to check any any
singularity like X going to three for
sure in this case you have to pay
attention to all the places where the
thing is infinite and then you want to
focus in on each one separately and
decide what's going on it at that
particular place when it's a negative
power so remember
DX over X as X goes to zero is bad and
DX over x squared is bad DX over X cubed
is bad all of them are even worse
so anything of this form is bad N equals
one two three these are the these are
the Redbox kinds all right that means
that any of the integrals that we did in
partial fractions which had a root which
had a factor of something the
denominator those are all divergent
integrals if you cross the singularity
not a single one of them makes sense
across the singularity right if you have
square roots and things like that then
you can repair things like that and
there are some interesting examples of
that such as with the arc sine function
and so forth
where you have an improper integral
which is really okay all right so that's
that's the best I can do it's
it's obviously something you get
experience with alright now I'm going to
move on and and this is more or less our
last topic yay but not quite well so I
should say it's our penultimate topic
right because we have one more lecture
all right so that our next topic is
series now we'll do it in a sort of a
concrete way today and then we'll do
whatever known as power series tomorrow
so let me tell you about series remember
we're talking about infinity and dealing
with infinity so we're not just talking
about any old series we're talking about
infinite series there is one infinite
series which is probably I which is
without question the most important and
useful series and that's the geometric
series but I'm going to introduce it
concretely first in a particular case if
I draw a picture of this sum which in
principle goes on forever you can see
that it goes someplace fairly easily by
marking out what's happening on the
number line the first step takes us to
one from zero and then if I add this
half I get to three halves right so the
first step was 1 and the second step was
1/2 now if I add this quarter in which
is the next piece then I get someplace
here but what I want to observe is that
is that I got I can look at it from the
other point of view I got when I move
this quarter I got halfway to two here
I'm putting two in green because I want
you to think of it as being the good
kind right
the kind that has a number they're not
one of the red kinds we're getting there
and we're almost there so the next stage
we get halfway again that's the eighth
and so forth and eventually we get to
two so this sum we write equals two all
right that's kind of a paradox because
we never get to two this is the paradox
that Zeno fussed with and his conclusion
you know with the rabbit and the hare
that would know the rabbit and the
tortoise sorry because hare tasted
throwing up anyway
the rabbit chasing the the tortoise his
conclusion you know I don't know if
you're aware of this but he understood
this paradox he said you know it doesn't
look like it ever gets there because
they're infinitely many times between
the time you know that the tortoise is
always behind always behind always
behind always behind so therefore it's
impossible that the tortoise catches up
right so do you know what his conclusion
was time does not exist
that was actually literally his
conclusion because he didn't understand
the possibility of continuum of time
because there are infinitely many things
that happen before
the tortoise caught up that was that was
the reason he I mean it's a long time
ago but you know people then he didn't
believe in continuum all right so anyway
that's a small point now the general
case here of geometric series is where I
put in a number a instead of a half here
so we had before so that's one plus a
plus a squared isn't quite the most
general but anyway I'll write this down
and you're certainly going to want to
remember that the formula for this and
the limit is 1 over 1 minus a and I
remind you that this only works when the
absolute value of a is strictly less
than 1 in other words when minus 1 is
strictly less than a is less than 1 and
that's really the issue that we're going
to want to worry about now we're
worrying about is this notion of convert
virgins and what goes wrong when when
there isn't convergence when there's a
when there's a divergence so let me
illustrate the divergences before going
on and this is what we have to avoid if
we're going to understand series so
here's an example when a is equal to 1
you get 1 plus 1 plus 1 plus etc and
that's equal to 1 over 1 minus 1 which
is 1 over 0 so this is not bad it's
almost right right it's sort of infinity
equals infinity at the edge here we
managed to get something which is sort
of almost right but you know it's we
don't consider this to be logically to
make complete sense so it's it's it's a
little dangerous and so we just say that
it diverges and we get rid of this so
we're still putting it in red alright a
bad guy here so this one diverges
similarly if I take a equals minus 1 I
get 1 minus 1 plus 1 minus 1 plus 1
because the odd and the even powers in
that formula alternate sign and this
bounces back and forth it never settles
down it's it it starts at 1 and then it
gets down to 0 and then it goes back up
to one down to zero back up to 1 it
doesn't settle down it bounces back and
forth it oscillates on the other hand if
you compare the right hand side what's
the right hand side it's 1 over 1 minus
minus 1 which is 1/2 all right so if you
just paid attention to the formula which
is what we were doing when we integrated
without thinking too hard about this you
get a number here but in fact that's
wrong actually it's kind of an
interesting number it's halfway between
the two between 0 & 1
so again there's some sort of vague
sense in which this is trying to be this
answer all right it's not it's not so
bad but we're still going to put this in
a red box all right because this is
what we call diverges so both of these
cases are divergent it only really works
when alpha is x1 a is less than 1 I'm
going to add one more case just to see
that mathematicians are slightly curious
about what goes goes on in other cases
so this is 1 plus 2 plus 2 squared plus
2 2 cube plus etc and that should be
equal to according to this formula 1
over 1 minus 2 which is negative 1 right
now this one is clearly wrong right this
one is totally wrong it certainly
diverges the right-hand side the
left-hand side is obviously infinite the
right-hand side is way off it's it's
negative 1 on the other hand it turns
out actually that mathematicians have
ways of making sense out of these in
number theory there's a strange system
where this is actually true and what
what happens in that system is that what
you have to throw out is the idea that 0
is less than 1 there are is no such
thing as negative numbers so this number
exists and it's it's the the additive
inverse of 1 it has this arithmetic
property but the the statement that this
is 1 as bigger than 0 does not make
sense so you have your choice either
this diverges or you have to throw out
something like this so that's a very
curious thing in higher mathematics
which if you get to number theory
there's fun stuff there all right ok but
for our purposes these things are all
out all right they're gone we're not
considering them only a between negative
1 and 1 all right
now I want to do something systemic and
it's more or less on the lines of the
powers that I'm erasing right now I want
to tell you about series which are kind
of borderline convergent and then next
time when we talk about power series
we'll come back to this very important
series which is the most important one
so now let's talk about some series
general notations and this will help you
with the last bit this is going to be
pretty much the same as what we did for
improper integrals namely first of all
I'm going to have capital SN which is
the sum of a n n equals 0 to capital n
and this is what we're calling a partial
sum and then the full limit which is
capital s if you like and N equals 0 to
infinity is just the limit as n goes to
infinity of the SS and then we have the
same kind of notation that we had before
which is there at these two choices
which is that it if the limit exists
that's the green choice and we say it
converges so we say the series converges
the series converges and then the other
case which is the limit does not exist
and we can say the series diverges
question the question was how did I get
to this and I will do that next time but
in fact of course you've seen it in high
school right this is a yeah yeah well
we'll do that next time the question was
how did we arrive sorry I didn't tell
you the question the question was how do
we arrive at this formula on the right
hand side here but we'll talk about that
next time all right so here's the basic
definition and and and what we're going
to recognize about series and I mean
give you a few examples and then we'll
do something systematic so the first
example well the first example is the
geometric series but the first example
that I'm going to discuss now in a
little bit of detail is the sum 1 over N
squared N equals 1 to infinity it turns
out that this series is very analogous
and we'll develop this analogy carefully
this series the integral from 1 to X DX
over x squared and we're going to
develop this analogy in detail later in
this lecture and this one is one of the
ones so now you have to go back and
actually remember this is one of the
ones you really want to memorize and you
should especially pay attention to the
ones with an infinity in them this one
is convergent and this series is
convergent now it turns out that
evaluating this is very easy this is one
it's easy to calculate evaluating this
is very tricky and euler did it and the
answer is PI squared over 6 now that's
an amazing calculation when it was done
very early in history of mathematics if
you look at another example
so maybe example 2 here if you look at 1
over n cubed and equals well you can't
start here at 0 by the way I get to
start wherever I want in these series
here I started with 0 here I started
with 1 and notice the reason why I
started is a bad idea to start with 0
was that 1 over 0 is undefined all right
so I'm just starting where it's
convenient for me and since I'm
interested mostly in the tail behavior
it doesn't matter to me so much where I
start although if I want an exact answer
I need to start exactly at N equals 1
all right this one is is similar to this
integral here all right which is
convergent again so there's a number
that you get and let's see what is it
something like 2/3 or something like
that alright for this for this number or
1/3 what does it know 1/2 I guess it's
1/2 this 1 is 1/2 you check that I'm not
positive but anyway just doing it in my
head quickly it seems to be 1/2 anyway
it's a easy number to calculate this one
over here stumped mathematicians
basically for all time it doesn't have
any kind of elementary form like this
and it was only very recently proved to
be rational people don't didn't even
couldn't even decide whether this was a
rational number or not but anyway that's
been resolved it is an irrational number
which is what people suspected yeah
question
yeah sorry okay I the rule of a rule of
mathematics you said why is this similar
I thought that similar was something
else and you're absolutely right and I
violated a rule of mathematics which is
that I used the this symbol for two
different things
these I should have written this symbol
here all right I'll create a new symbol
here the question of whether this
converges or this converges is these are
this the same type of question and we'll
see why they're the same question in a
few minutes but in fact the wiggle I
used similar I used for the connection
between functions what the things that
are really similar are that 1 over n
resembles Y over x squared so I
apologize I didn't and you thought that
that that this was the definition of
that that's actually the reason why
these things correspond so closely that
is that that the Riemann sum is close to
this but that doesn't mean they're equal
the Riemann sum only works when the
Delta X goes to 0 the way that we're
going to get a connection between these
two as we will in just a second is with
a Riemann sum with we're going to what
we're going to do use is a Riemann sum
with Delta X plus 1 all right and then
that will be the connection between all
right that's absolutely right
all right so in order to illustrate
exactly this idea that we've just that
you've just come up with and in fact
that we're going to use we'll do this
same thing but we're going to do it on
the example sum 1 over N
so here's example 3 and it's going to be
sum 1 over N N equals 1 to infinity and
what we're now going to see is that it
corresponds to this integral here and
we're going to show therefore that this
thing diverges but we're going to do
this in more carefully we're going to do
this in some detail so that you see what
it is that the correspondence is between
these quantities and the same sort of
reasoning applies to these other
examples so here we go
I'm going to take the integral and draw
the picture of the Riemann sum so here's
the level 1 and here's the function y
equals 1 over X and I'm going to take
the Riemann sum with Delta x equals 1
and that's going to be closely connected
to the series that I have but now I have
to decide whether I want a lower Riemann
sum or an upper Riemann sum and actually
I'm going to check both of them because
both of them are illuminating first
we'll do the upper Riemann sum well
that's this staircase here so we'll call
this the upper Riemann sum and let's
check what its levels are this is not to
scale this level should be 1/2 so if
this is 1 and this is 2 then that levels
supposed to be 1/2 and this next level
should be 1/3 that's that's how the
Riemann sums are working out
and now I have the following phenomenon
let's just look let's cut it off at the
end stage so that means that I'm going
the integral is from 1 to n DX over X
and the Riemann sum is something that's
bigger than it because the area's are
enclosing the area of the curved region
and that's going to be the area of the
first box which is 1 plus the area of
the second box which is 1/2 plus the
area of the third box which is 1/3 all
the way up to the last one but the last
one is is is starts at n minus 1 so it
has 1 over n minus 1 there are not n
boxes here there are only n minus 1
boxes because the distance between 1 and
n is n minus 1 all right so this is n
minus 1 terms however if I use the
notation for partial sum which is 1 plus
1 over 2 plus all the way up to 1 over n
minus 1 plus 1 over N in other words I
go out to the nth one which is what I
would ordinarily do then this sum that I
have here is certainly less than I said
because there's one more term there and
so here I have an integral which is
underneath this sum SN
now this is going to allow us to prove
conclusively that the so I'm just going
to rewrite this prove conclusively that
the sum diverges why is that because
this term here we can calculate this is
log X evaluated at 1 and n which is the
same thing as log and minus 0
all right the quantity log n minus log
log 1 which is 0 and so what we have
here is that log n is less than SN all
right and clearly this goes to infinity
right as n goes to infinity this thing
goes to infinity so we're done
all right we've shown divergence now the
way I'm going to use the lower Riemann
sum is to recognize that we've captured
the rate appropriately that is not only
do I have a lower bound like this but I
have an upper bound which is very
similar so if I use the upper Riemann
sorry the lower Riemann sum again with
Delta x equals 1 then
I have that the integral from 1 to n of
DX over X is bigger than well what are
the terms going to be if I fit them
underneath if I fit them underneath I'm
missing the first term that is the box
is going to be 1/2 height it's going to
be this this lower piece so I'm missing
this first term so it'll be 1/2 plus 1/3
plus all right we'll keep on going but
now the last one instead of being 1 over
n minus 1 is going to be 1 over n this
is again a total of n minus 1 terms so
this is the lower Riemann sum and now we
can recognize that this is exactly equal
to well so I'll put it over here this is
exactly equal to SN minus 1 minus the
first term so we missed the first term
but we got all the rest of them so if I
put this to the other side remember this
is the login if I put this to the other
side I have the other side of this bound
I have that SN is less than if I reverse
it log n plus 1 and so I've trapped it
on the other side here I have the lower
bound so I'm going to combine that those
together so all told I have this this
correspondence here it is the size of
log n is trapped between sorry the size
of SN which is relatively hard to
calculate and understand exactly is
trapped between log N and log n plus 1
yeah question
this step here is the step that you're
concerned about so this step is a
geometric argument which is analogous to
this step alright it's the it's the same
type of argument and in this case it's
that the rectangles are on top and so
the area represented on the right hand
side is less than the area represented
on the on this side and this is the same
type of thing except that the rectangles
are underneath so the sum of the areas
of the rectangles is less than the area
under the curve all right so I've now
trapped this this quantity and I'm now
going to state the the sort of general
results so here's what's known as
integral comparison it's this it's this
double arrow correspondence in the
general case or in a very general case
there's actually even more cases where
it works but this is a good case and
convenient this is called integral
comparison and it has how it comes with
hypotheses but it follows the same
argument that I just gave if f of X is
decreasing and it's positive then
the some F n N equals one to infinity
minus the integral from 1 to infinity of
f of X DX is less than F of 1 that's
basically what we showed we showed that
the difference between SN and log n was
at most 1 all right now if both of them
are and and the sum and the integral
converge or diverge together that is
they either both converge or both
diverge this is the type of test that we
like because then we can just convert
the question of convergence over here to
this question of convergence over on the
other side now I remind you that it's
incredibly hard to calculate these
numbers whereas these numbers are easier
to calculate our goal is to have this to
reduce things to simpler things and in
this case sums infinite sums are much
harder than infinite integrals all right
so that's the integral comparison and
now I have one last bit on comparisons
that I need to tell you about and this
is very much like what we did with
integrals which is a so called limit
comparison the limit comparison says the
following if F of n is similar to G of n
we recall that that means F of n over G
of n tends to 1 as n goes to infinity
and we're in the positive case so let's
just say GN is positive then no it
doesn't even well then um some FN some G
uh even both same thing is above either
both converge we're both alright this is
just saying that if the if they's behave
the same way in the tail which is all we
really care about then they have similar
behavior similar convergence properties
and let me give you a couple examples so
here's one example if you take the sum 1
over N squared plus 1 square root
this is going to be replaced by
something simpler which is the main term
here which is one over square root of N
squared which we recognize as some 1
over N which diverges so this guy is one
of the red guys on the red team now we
have another example which is let's say
the square root of n I don't know to the
fifth minus M Squared now if you have
something where that's negative in the
drama you kind of do have to watch out
that the denominator makes sense it
isn't zero so we're going to be careful
and start this at N equals two in which
case the first term is you know right I
don't I don't like one over zero is a
term in my series so I'm just gonna be a
little careful about how I said I was
kind of lazy here I could have started
this one at zero for instance all right
so here's the here's a picture now this
I get I just replaced by its main term
which is 1 over N to the fifth square
root which is some 1 over N to the 5
halves which converges all right the
power is bigger than 1 1 is the divider
for these things in it and it just
misses this one converges all right so
these are the typical ways in which in
which these convergence processes are
used all right so I have one more thing
for you which is an advertisement for
next time
and I have this demo here which I can
grant okay but you will see this next
time so here's a question for you to
think about overnight but don't ask
friends you have to think about yourself
so here's the problem
here are some blocks which I acquired
one of my kids left home
anyway yeah
now that that will happen to you too in
about 40 years so now so now here you
are these are blocks so now here's the
question that we're going to deal with
next time I'm going to build it maybe
I'll put it over here because I want to
have some room to head this way I want
to I want to stack them up so that Oh
didn't work going to stack them up in
the following way
I want to do it so that the top one is
completely to the right of the bottom
one that's the question can it can I do
that can I get can I build this up so
let's let's see here ah it's just I just
seem to be missing but anyway what I'm
going to do is I'm going to try to build
this and we're going to see how far we
can get with this next time